les élections départementales au plus
près de chez vous ou 19h07 c'est l'heure
de votre journal de campagne
avec vous lilian melet et comme tous les
sens gros plan sur un canton
oui nous prenons aujourd'hui la
direction du morvan avec le nouveau
canton de corbigny qui regroupe en gros
les anciens canton de lormes de brienon
et donc de corbigny trois cantons de
gauche un fief de la majorité
départementale sur les terres du député
socialiste christian paul
sauf que comme partout dans la nièvre la
droite a réalisé une percée aux
dernières municipales en prenant la
mairie de corbigny et le front national
progresse dans cet espace rural
régis guillon et fabien madigou au
centre de l'écran le maire et
conseillers sortants fabien bazin 48 ans
socialiste et conseiller général du
canton de lormes depuis deux mandats
un canton tout comme celui de
brinon-sur-beuvron rattaché désormais
aux nouveaux cantons de corps bing l'élu
du morvan depuis 15 ans se lance dans
ces départementale sous la bannière de
vivre la nièvre sur son affiche de
campagne son appartenance au ps n'est
pas indiqué fabien bazin sont explique
franchement le sujet des étiquettes
n'intéresse pas grand monde
moi je suis socialiste je crois que tout
le monde le sait mes colistiers ne sont
pas encartés c'est un choix personnel
ce qui compte vraiment dans cette
élection c'est de se mettre encore une
fois au service de nos concitoyens au
quotidien et chaque jour ça il ya un
vrai enjeu pour inventer une nouvelle
proximité avec cette élection
départementale
il faut que on gagne en proximité non
pas qu'on perde
il faut qu'on soit efficace parce que
les sujets de mobilité on l'a vu
aujourd'hui de santé d'emploi
ça nécessite une présence de tous les
jours de chaque instant aux côtés de nos
concitoyens si on veut faire réussir la
nièvre une nièvre et surtout un canton
de corbigny que fabien bazin espère
remporter avec à ses côtés anne vers 1
une jeune enseignante sur la même
longueur d'onde que son colistier mettre
un petit peu de côté la politique
nationale qui on voudrait faire de
de l'action de terrain en fait et non
plus sans s'accrocher à des idées très
nationale sur la partie morvan du canton
le duo base un vérin peut être serein
l'électorat y est encore majoritairement
de gauche
en revanche un peu plus en pleine
l'échiquier politique a bougé depuis les
dernières municipales avec la bascule à
droite de corbigny la droite justement
dans ces élections départementales la
voici incarné par l'ump jean charles
richard aux côtés de maria soudan
l'homme n'est pas un inconnu des
électeurs maires adjoints de corbigny et
surtout président de la communauté de
communes du pays corbigeois c'est vrai
que ce canton est à bien des égards
emblématique parce qu'il a été un canton
historique de la majorité départementale
depuis une cinquantaine d'années il
était marqué par les présences forte
comme ça du dr perrier le docteur magnon
aujourd'hui on l'a vu dans les mines ou
lors des municipales dans dans ce
département
je crois qu'il ya un phénomène d'usure
il ya une aspiration au changement plus
que jamais l'alternance est possible je
crois qu'on en est arrivé à la fin de la
des candidatures de témoignage
autre candidat de poids sur le nouveau
canton de corbigny
le patron du front national 58 marcel
stéphan par ailleurs conseiller
municipal delorme et conseiller régional
de bourgogne
comme à chaque élection l'élu fn met
dans le même panier ump et ps et en
appellent leurs électeurs déçus le
clivage gauche droite pour nous il
n'existe plus on l'a vu encore dernières
élections partielles du doubs les
beaucoup de codes de l'ump appelle à
voter socialiste donc ça veut dire que
l'ump est ce comme on les nomme
c'est une réalité les gens commencent à
se rendre compte que la situation dans
laquelle il se trouve
c'est pas en votant pour les
responsables de cette situation qu'ils
vont changer les choses
est ce assez c'est vraiment nouveau et
on le voit plus que bon on est on est
souvent sur le terrain avec le fn en
embuscade
une droite revigorée et sans doute une
forte abstention comme par le passé
la gauche va devoir batailler ferme pour
conserver le territoire constitue
désormais par le canton de corbigny en
nièvre en tout cas les dernières
élections locales ont montré que des
bastions socialistes pouvaient tomber
ajoutons que sont aussi candidat sur ce
canton de corbigny isabelle liron et
hervé rivière pour le front de gauche
je scrute en relayant ce sera évidemment
la participation oui on sait qu'elle a
été faible pour les dernières élections
européennes et municipales et le
changement de mode de scrutin et le
redécoupage des cantons pourraient
encore augmenter l'abstention qui jouera
du coup un rôle important dans ces
élections départementales
au premier comme au second tour
l'abstention sera une des clés de ce
scrutin à voter même avis normes ayant
obtenu plus de 50% des voix dès le
premier tour ne pourra être élu qu'à
condition d'avoir mobilisé un quart des
électeurs de son canton
sinon il y aura un deuxième tour avec
les deux binômes arrivés en tête
un troisième binôme pourra aussi se
maintenir uniquement s'il a obtenu douze
ennemis % des inscrits qu'il faut
obtenir 12 et demi pour cent des
inscrits pour pouvoir être qualifié pour
le second tour
comme c'est un scrutin où l'abstention
est importante
très schématiquement ça veut dire qu'il
faut obtenir au 1er tour 22 23 % pour
pouvoir être qualifié au second tour
l'abstention pourrait donc bien être le
véritable arbitre de ces départementale
elle ne cesse d'augmenter et en 2011 et
l'arrêt atteint plus de 55% à ces
élections de mars qu'il sera la
mobilisation
si à quelques facteurs qui peuvent
contribuer meilleure mobilisation le
fait que justement c'est une élection
nationale
donc il y aura l'idée encore plus nette
d'une sorte de test national ça peut
contribuer à mobiliser parfois par
antagonisme parfois pour justement
exprimé son mécontentement mais ça peut
être un facteur
donc en gros on se dit que par rapport
aux 55 56 % qu'il y avait eu en 2011
on pourrait se trouver dans peut-être
48% peut-être 52 % d'abstention donc
éventuellement un petit peu de
mobilisation accrue mais il y aura
probablement pas de révolution
riton ses électeurs les 22 et 29 mars
et comme chaque soir à la campagne est
autrement via les réseaux sociaux oui
sur un autre sérieux d'abord avec la
colère du conseiller régional ump de
saône-et-loire gérald gordat qui casse
le thermomètre en reprochant aux médias
la progression électorale du front
national
les partis politiques ne sont pour rien
bien sûr avec beaucoup plus d'humour a
drogué du twitte le socialiste pascal
simon absence qui attaque le bilan de la
majorité départementale avec 50 nuance
de regrets on lui laisse son analyse
politique mais la formule est largement
acceptée sans les menottes
le choix est la leur tenir trois
semaines mais pas lyon pour celui qui
les photos et c'est toi c'est tout
public oui tout public des instantanés
de campagne qui donne un aperçu de
l'ambiance d'abord un café politique
avec le député laurent grandguillaume
pour le binôme ps de dijon 4 1/2 pour le
député au passage et puis pendant que
certains vides les verts d'autres les
lave en tout cas au moment de la photo
comme l'ump sébastien martins candidats
sur givry on va vite pendant que sur
dijon 6 céline maglica et andré gervais
font campagne à vélo plus quelques
selphy au passage est ce qu'on a vu
cette photo là voilà cette photo et puis
très rapidement un peu de poésie dans un
monde de brutes avec le leader de
l'opposition de droite en saône-et-loire
andré accary qui nous montre qu'il avait
un rêve d'enfant les trains électriques
voilà c'est fini pour ce soir s'il vient
d'un gros plan sur saint vallier en
saône et loire